hello and welcome back because you loved
our first video on top UI design tips
we've created part two for you which
will be even more exciting the truth is
you don't need a design background
special talents or a University degree
to create beautiful UI designs by
mastering the key principles tips and
tricks anyone can create exceptional UI
designs that people love whether you're
a designer developer marketer or simply
curious about UI design these tips are
for you let's dive into today's tips and
keep pushing ing Your Design skills to
the next level tip number one experiment
with creative layouts the traditional
approach of a vertical list of
text-based options can sometimes come
across as Bland and unengaging the
standard layout offers limited
opportunities for visual differentiation
and while it provides Clarity it doesn't
always contribute to a memorable user
experience what if we could break free
from the constraints of the typical list
of options layout an exciting
alternative is to reimagine them as
selectable cards this approach adds a
new layer of interaction and visual
appeal to the user interface each card
can feature labels colors and even icons
or images providing more context and
richness to the options presented such
an approach not only increases the
aesthetic appeal but also AIDS in making
the information more digestible and the
interface more
engaging tip number two reduce user
barrier by exposing content directly
imagine this you're scrolling through a
new app and the first thing you see is a
big banner saying discover 100 plus
recipes selected by our chefs it sounds
exciting but it's also an extra step you
have to tap on it to see the actual
recipes that's the interaction cost in
action which we can Define as the
cognitive physical and time effort a
user has to exert to reach their goal in
today's fast-paced world users are
looking for immediate value by hiding
content behind banners you're creating
an unnecessary barrier between the user
and the value your app provides
this interaction cost may seem trivial
but it can add up especially when the
user is new to the app and unsure about
investing time and effort in it instead
imagine this you open the same app but
this time you immediately see a curated
list of top 10 recommended recipes no
tapping needed the content is right
there this does a couple of things it
adds quick value the user instantly sees
the value your app provides making them
more likely to engage further it reduces
friction
the fewer steps a user has to take to
reach their goal the better the user
experience that means increased user
attention and more interaction within
your app it adds relevancy when you
expose content directly you have the
opportunity to showcase the most
relevant or popular items making it more
likely that the user will find something
that interests them right away tip
number three design for the thumb Zone
mobile devices are often operated using
just one hand and primarily the thumb
therefore when you're designing a mobile
interface it's important to keep the tum
zones in mind this is the area of the
screen easily reachable with the thumb
placing key elements like buttons
navigation links and calls to action
within the thumb Zone makes it easier
for users to interact with your Design
Elements positioned outside of this area
can be difficult to reach and could lead
to user frustration or misclicks so when
you're laying out your design make sure
the most used features are easily
accessible within the thumb Zone by
doing so you enhance usability and make
your interface more userfriendly let's
have a look at two UI design examples in
the first screen the CTA is located
outside of the thumb Zone which means
that users would need to stretch or
adjust their grip to reach it this can
cause frustration and inconvenience
especially for users who are on the go
or have limited mobility in the second
screen the CTA is thoughtfully
positioned within the thumb Zone which
is a common area where users thumbs
naturally rest when holding their mobile
devices tip number four turn empty
States into opportunities when a user
encounters an empty State it's like
hitting a roadblock an empty screen with
no guidance or actionable steps can
leave them feeling lost and frustrated
it's a missed opportunity to guide and
engage users a bare empty State such as
a screen simply saying you have no
projects fails to provide users with any
value or Direction it's a dead end that
can make users feel stuck and unsure of
what to do next next conversely a
well-designed empty State can be a
powerful tool to educate engage and
encourage users to take action it's a
chance to turn a potential negative
experience into a positive one for
example an empty state that says start
managing your projects and stay
organized immediately offers a solution
to the user's problem it doesn't stop
there though with an accompanying
illustration it becomes visually
appealing and less daunting by adding
actionable tips like invite team members
to collaborate on a project for better
communication and set deadlines for
tasks to keep everyone on track it
provides clear steps for the user to
take finally a CTA button saying create
new project gives them a direct way to
take action last but not least tip
number five use visual
cues we could have presented all these
tips in a Texton format but we chose to
use visual examples why because visuals
make your learning and any user's
interaction with a design far more
engaging and memorable visual cues do
more than just add flare or personality
to your designs they help users
understand your message faster and
enhance overall user experience by
making information easier to grasp to
show the impact visual cues can have
compare the following designs the first
one without the visual cues versus the
second one with the visual cues a huge
difference right now let's have a look
at another example of using visual cues
to design better UI for email messages
in the first design you can see a UI
that doesn't apply the principle of
visual cues while this UI design is
functional there are opportunities to
enhance the user experience and improve
the overall usability of the email inbox
even more using icons with a set of
colors and a first initial letter in the
middle could be a creative and Visually
appealing way to represent senders in an
email inbox or messaging app a more
effective way to represent senders is to
use images of people and logos of
companies with that users can easily
identify the sender and quickly
understand the context of the message
love these tips then consider joining
more than 8,000 amazing designers
marketers and developers who have
already downloaded the uiux design
Playbook and unlocked more than 90
awesome UI design tips tricks and
strategies let us know in the comment if
you wanted to see part three that is all
for today keep designing beautiful
things and I will see you in the next
one have a beautiful day